i'd like to talk to you today about the
human brain which is what we do research
on at the university of california
just think about this problem for a
second here is a lump of flesh about
three pounds which you can hold in the
palm of your hand but it can contemplate
the vastness of interstellar space it
can contemplate the meaning of infinity
ask questions about the meaning of its
own existence about the nature of god
and this is truly the most amazing thing
in the world it's the greatest mystery
confronting human beings how does this
all come about well the brain as you
know is made up of neurons
looking at neurons here there are 100
billion neurons in the adult human brain
and each neuron makes something like a
thousand to ten thousand contacts with
other neurons in the brain and based on
this people are calculated that the
number of permutations and combinations
of brain activity exceeds the number of
elementary particles in the universe so
how do you go about studying the brain
one approach is to look at patients who
had lesions in different part of the
brain and study changes in their
behavior this is what i spoke about in
the last 10 today i'll talk about a
different approach which is to put
electrodes in different parts of the
brain and actually record the activity
of individual nerve cells in the brain
sort of eavesdrop on the activity of
nerve cells in the brain
now
one recent discovery that has been made
by researchers in italy in palma by
yakima ridgelassi and his colleagues is
a group of neurons called mirror neurons
which are in the front of the brain in
the frontal lobes
now it turns out there are neurons which
are called ordinary motor command
neurons in the front of the brain which
have been known for over 50 years these
neurons will fire when a person performs
a specific action for example if i do
that and reach and grab an apple a motor
command neuron in the front of my brain
will fire if i reach out and pull an
object another neuron will fire
commanding me to pull my pull that
object these are called motor command
neurons be known for a long time but
what regionality found was a subset of
these neurons maybe about 20 of them
will also fire when i'm looking at
somebody else performing the same action
so here's a neuron that fires when i
reach and grab something but it also
fires when i watch joe reaching and
grabbing something and this is truly
astonishing because as though this
neuron is adopting the other person's
point of view and it's also almost as
it's perfect performing a virtual
reality simulation of the other person's
action
now what is the significance of these
mirror neurons for one thing they must
be involved in things like imitation and
emulation because to imitate a complex
act requires my brain to adopt the other
person's point of view so this is
important for imitation and emulation
well why is that important well let's
take a look at the next slide
so how do you do imitation why is
imitation important mirror neurons in
imitation emulation now let's look at
culture the phenomenon of human culture
if you go back in time about 75 100 000
years ago let's look at human evolution
it turns out that something very
important happened around 75 000 years
ago and that is there's a sudden
emergence and rapid spread of a number
of skills that are unique to human
beings like like tool use the use of
fire use of shelters and of course
language and the ability to read
somebody else's mind and interpret that
person's behavior all of that happened
relatively quickly even though the human
brain had achieved its present size
almost three or four hundred thousand
years ago hundred thousand years ago all
of this happened very very quickly and i
claim that what happened was
the sudden emergence of a sophisticated
mirror neuron system which allowed you
to emulate and imitate other people's
actions so that when there was a sudden
uh accidental discovery by one member of
the group say use a fire or a particular
type of tool instead of dying out to
spread rapidly horizontally across the
population or was transmitted vertically
down the generations so this made of
illusion suddenly lamarckian instead of
darwinian in darwinian evolution is slow
takes hundreds of thousands of years a
polar bear to evolve a coat will take
thousands of generations maybe a hundred
thousand years a human being a child can
just watch its parent
kill
another polar bear and skin it and put
the skin on its body fur on the body and
learn it in one step what the polar bear
took a hundred thousand years to learn
it can learn in five minutes maybe ten
minutes right and then once it's learned
this it spreads by in geometric
proportion across the population and
this is the basis of this imitation of
complex skills is what we call culture
as the basis of civilization
now there's another kind of meta neuron
which is involved in something quite
different and that is
there are many neurons justice that are
meta neurons for action that are mirror
neurons for touch in other words if
somebody touches me my hand the neuron
in the somatosensory cortex and the
sensory region of the brain fires but
the same neuron in some cases will fire
when i simply watch another person being
touched so it's empathizing the other
person being touched so most of them
will fire when i'm touched in different
locations different neurons for
different locations but a subset of them
will fire even when i watch somebody
else being touched in the same location
so here again you have neurons which are
involved in empathy now the question
then arises if i simply watch another
person being touched why do i not get
confused and literally feel that touch
sensation
merely by watching somebody being
touched i empathize with that person but
i don't literally feel the touch well
that's because you've got receptors in
your skin touch and pain receptors going
back into your brain and saying don't
worry you're not being touched so
empathize by all means with the other
person
but do not actually experience the touch
otherwise you'll get confused and
muddled okay so there's a feedback
signal that vetoes the signal of the
mirror neuron preventing you from
consciously experiencing that touch but
if you remove the arm you simply
anesthetize my arm so you put an
injection into my arm anesthetize the
brachial plexus so the arm is numb
there's no sensations coming in if i now
watch you being touched i literally feel
it in my hand in other words you've
dissolved the barrier between you and
other human beings so i call them
gandhi neurons or empathy neurons
and this is not in some abstract
metaphorical sense
all that's separating you from him from
the other person is your skin remove the
skin you experience that person's touch
in your mind you have dissolved the
barrier between you and other human
beings and this of course is the basis
of much of eastern philosophy and that
is there's no real independent self
aloof from other human beings inspecting
the world and inspecting other people
you're in fact connected not just via
facebook and internet you're actually
quite literally connected by your
neurons and this whole chains of neurons
around this room talking to each other
and there is no real distinctiveness of
your consciousness from somebody else's
consciousness and this is not
mumbo-jumbo philosophy it emerges from
our understanding of basic neuroscience
so you have a patient with a phantom
limb if arm has been removed and you
have a phantom and you watch somebody
else being touched you feel it in your
phantom
now the astonishing thing is if you have
pain in your phantom limb you squeeze
the other person's hand massage the
other person's hand
that relieves the pain in your phantom
hand
almost as though the neuron were
obtaining relief from merely watching
somebody else being massaged
so here you have my last slide
for the longest time people have
regarded science and humanities as being
distinct c.p snow spoke of the two
cultures science on the one hand
humanities on the other never the twain
shall meet so i'm saying the mirror
neuron system lies at the interface
allowing you to
think think about issues like
consciousness representation of self
what separates you from other human
beings water loves allows you to
empathize with other human beings and
also even things like the emergence of
culture and civilization which is unique
to human beings thank you
traffic is a global epidemic
us traffic is creating 45 of the world's
air pollution in the uk time wasted in
traffic costs 20 billion a year would
you pay for cleaner air on a faster
commute stockholm put it to a vote i
voted for it yes i voted for it i vote
for it we're not old enough to vote vote
we had to do something in stockholm to
improve the environment and to get a
better flow in the traffic we put a
price on taking your car into the
central parts of stockholm and we call
that congestion charges
if you start a system like this and it
doesn't work on the first day
then you will be in big trouble
it must be perfect from day one
there are 18 empty gates to the city
each is equipped with cameras pictures
are taken of the rear and front license
plates these pictures are sent to a
central system that identifies the
license plates and makes sure that the
right person pays for the right passages
one of the obstacles we overcame was the
ocr the optical character reading of the
license plate we went out to ibm's
global organization and the r d centers
and find a very good software we could
use and we managed to implement it in
two months time this is the heart of the
system where all images and passages are
being processed over 99 of all pictures
are correctly identified
no it's nice this is how it should be
all the time
behind me you can see the traffic and
the clock is 6 pm before we had the
congestion charging the traffic was
chewing up at this time of the day
i think it's a good idea because i think
that we should take care of the
environment in the city the traffic went
down with about 22 percent and the air
pollution was about 14 better
it's a huge international interest from
different parts of the world from
the united states from latin america
from china and it's
really a pleasure to tell people not
what we are planning to do but what we
actually have done in stockholm i voted
for it yes i did not my husband so
i did i think he is not thinking like me
for
the future i'm thinking for the children
and the grandchildren